des polémiques au festival de cannes il
y en a eu depuis la première édition en
1960 le film franco-italien la dolce
vita de federico fellini obtient la
palme d'or une récompense du jury qui
n'est pas du goût de tous le public n'a
pas été très très très satisfait ce
n'est pas on peut dire à trélon sellini
qu'on a eu la freinerait ils bidonnent
davis l ' on ne peut pas dire que ce
genre de ville un film très réussi
six ans plus tard autre scandale le long
métrage belles dames et vilains
messieurs du réalisateur italien pietro
germi partage la palme d'or avec un
homme et une femme de claude lelouch
mais le ton change avec l'autre palme
d'or attribuée à pietro germi pour son
film
mesdames et messieurs un haut niveau de
vulgarité clament les opposants
la prochaine fois répond j'ai remis je
vous promets de faire un film ennuyeux
bref un palmarès qui n'a pas suscité
l'indifférence mai 68 la fièvre de la
capitale a envahi la croisette sensible
à la mobilisation parisienne
plusieurs réalisateurs jean luc godard
claude lelouch ou françois truffaut
demande l'arrêt du festival et occupe le
palais la radio donne des nouvelles
heure par heure on annonce que des
usines sont occupés que telle et telle
ferme que là que le train ne marche plus
maintenant ça va être les métros des bus
alors si on annonce toutes les heures et
le festival de cannes continue
et bien c'est franchement ridicule et
après la démission de plusieurs membres
du jury le festival sera finalement
interrompu cinq jours avant sa fin
officielle sans aucun prix
en 1973 cannes digère mal la grande
boucle en compétition le film de marco
ferreri raconte l'histoire de quatre
hommes enfermés dans une maison pour
jouir de tous les plaisirs
jusqu'à ce que mort s'ensuive la
critique se déchaîne le public hurle
lors de la projection
c'est un scandale à scandale le don de
prendre un papillon quatorze ans plus
tard la palme d'or attribuée à
l'unanimité à sous le soleil de satan de
maurice pialat déclenché us et
simplement des festivaliers le
réalisateur français les affronte alors
avec berne
je ne devais pas faillir à ma réputation
je suis surtout content ce soir pour
tous les cris et les sifflets que vous
m'adressez et
si vous ne m'aimez pas je peux vous dire
que je ne vous aime pas non plus depuis
d'autres réalisateurs ont fait scandale
à cannes les polémiques qui contribuent
à la légende de leur fils mais aussi à
celle du festival
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]